salut julien ça va as tu montes
maintenant bon dit non tu as déjà eu les
couilles bleus toi aubin l'hérésie c'est
bon et bien bon ok alors une fois une
soirée déguisée énorme je veux pas
savoir aujourd'hui dans dtc on va parler
de testicules et que vous en possédez
personnellement ou pas je vous conseille
de rester parce que dans tous les cas ça
vous concerne et non seulement ça vous
concerne
mais ça devrait vous intéresser parmi
les mythes et légendes sur le corps
humain il en est un qui traverse les
âges et qui sert de moyen de pression
voire de chantage depuis des générations
le mythe des couilles
[Musique]
alors pour celles et ceux qui n'auraient
jamais entendu parler que dit cette
légende les couilles bleu blue bose dans
la langue de britney spears c'est quoi
et bien une vieille croyance raconte que
lorsqu'un homme est excitée sexuellement
et que ça ne débouche pas sur une
éjaculation ses testicules prennent une
couleur bleutée et deviennent
extrêmement douloureuse ce qui lui fait
courir un grave danger pour sa santé
alors autant lever le voile tout de
suite sur ce mystère
c'est la vérité mais en partie seulement
donc rester jusqu'au bout je vais pas
tout spoil et tout de suite
commençons par la douleur effectivement
après une excitation sexuelle prolonger
si ça ne se passe pas comme espéré
ça fait mal et je ne parle pas que de
lego masculin mal placé je parle des
couilles
croyez moi sur parole c'est la vérité
comme bien souvent dans ce genre de cas
de figure à la frontière entre
l'embarras du quotidien est un réel
problème médical
rien n'a été véritablement démontré par
des études scientifiques en bonne et due
forme
mais sous la pression populaire quelques
spécialistes ont tenté d'y voir plus
clair et ont émis des hypothèses
voici leur histoire bon une érection
vous savez comment ça marche
bon en gros mécaniquement on a une
érection quand les deux corps caverneux
qui sont situées de chaque côté du pénis
se gorgent de sang ce qui rigidifie
l'ensemble dans ces cas là les vaisseaux
chargés d'approvisionner la zone en sang
se dilate et pour empêcher le taux de
retomber les vaisseaux chargés d'évacuer
la zone se contracte tout bien regarder
à l'intérieur et ça concerne les
vaisseaux qu'il irrigue tout le secteur
y compris les testicules
après l'éjaculation l'ensemble se
relâchent et tout le monde rentre chez
soi mais si l'éjaculation n'intervient
pas bon bah l'érection elle comprend que
c'est pas le moment donc elle disparaît
mais tout le reste de la zone reste
congestionné notamment au niveau de
l'épididyme epide
alors l'épididyme c'est un petit tuyau
qui est replié sur lui même qui s'étale
sur une partie des testicules et à
l'intérieur duquel les cellules
spermatiques font leur petit bonhomme de
chemin et il semblerait que cet organe
souffrent tout particulièrement de la
congestion puisque dans ces cas là on
parle d'hypertension de l'épididyme et
ce serait ça qui donne cette lourdeur et
ses douleurs au niveau des testicules
alors ça c'est pour la version la plus
sérieuse qui a été décrite en l'an 2000
par des médecins dans une revue
pédiatrique
oui je sais c'est cholet d'autres
hypothèses pas forcément incompatible
avec la première avance que les
vésicules séminales et la prostate
pourrait aussi être en cause
les premières stock un liquide qu'on
appelle le liquide séminal calé gect au
moment de l'éjaculation et qui va se
mélanger aux autres liquides qui forment
le sperme
oui le sperme c'est une sorte de
cocktail
parmi ces lits qu'il ya aussi le liquide
prostatique qui est produit par lé bas
la prostate la prostate c'est oui ces
deux organes pourrait être dix ont
contrarié d'avoir bossé pour rien ce qui
accentuerait la sensation de tension et
de lourdeurs et par contrarier j'entends
engorgé si vous voyez ce que je veux
dire mais attention la prostate et les
vésicules séminales elle se situe pas
dans les testicules pas loin ok mais pas
dedans bon et puis là encore il ne
s'agit que d'une hypothèse non vérifier
scientifiquement bon donc on a vu le
côté couilles mais le côté bleu alors
certains médecins avance une hypothèse
selon laquelle du sang pauvre en oxygène
stagnerait dans les tissus et les
colorés en bleu savez comme la bouche
des gens quand ils respirent fabien bon
là pour le coup c'est probablement
plutôt de lors du folklore mais je vous
le donne quand même mon observation
personnelle ne m'a jamais permis
d'observer ce phénomène coloré mais bon
en même temps je suis daltonien
alors si à vous ça vous est arrivé ou si
vous avez constaté le phénomène
n'hésitez pas à nous raconter ça dans
les commentaires par contre les photos
de la belle pour être complet on va dire
aussi que sans surprise y aurait aussi
une dimension psychologique à tout ça à
base de fierté de frustration
oui c'est frustrant attention ça veut
pas dire que la douleur existe pas mais
ça peut amplifier la façon dont elle est
ressentie et c'est là qu'on en arrive au
dernier point et pas des moindres les
couilles bleus sont souvent brandie
comme une menace
quelle image mentale et chaude mais je
m'explique je veux parler du chantage du
type
alors soyons très clairs tous les hommes
ne sont pas concernés par le phénomène y
en a qui vivent ça très bien sans aucune
douleur
et pour ceux qui connaissent c'est pas
forcément à se les connaît dans une
porte non plus pendant des jours en tout
cas ensuite les couilles bleus ça n'est
pas du tout dangereux pour la santé
juste désagréable au pire très
désagréable des fois mais pas dangereux
et puis surtout des solutions existent
il ya un traitement gratuit
très simple d'utilisation et plutôt pas
désagréable il s'agit tout simplement de
provoquer une éjaculation et tout rentre
dans l'ordre
et a priori se provoquer une éjaculation
les gens savent faire tout seul enfin si
vous voulez aider pas de problème mais
ne vous sentez pas coupable et ne vous
sentez pas obligés
d'ailleurs il me semble important de
porter en fait à votre connaissance ou
de faire un petit rappel au moins ça
fait jamais de mal
le clitoris aussi à des érections avec
le même mécanisme que pour le pénis à
base de sang caf lui dans la zone est
oui et du coup pour les mêmes raisons la
vulve e bleu ça existe aussi mais
bizarrement on en parle beaucoup moins
sa tête un lien avec le fait qu'on a
longtemps considéré qu'un rapport sexuel
ça prend fin avec l'orgasme masculin et
que l'orgasme féminin
je vous laisse voilà détester c'est fini
pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve très
vite pour une nouvelle vidéo d'ici là
mais prenez soin de vos organes génitaux
et ceux des autres pas si vous le
demandez si vous avez envie bien sûr
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]